siamo tornati ragazzi e stefy il
magnifico che il mio compagno per
eccellenza di ciò che siamo contro i new
svizzera anche il tag il tag suggerisce
che faranno cacare vediamo allora ecco
io sono del t 1 dvd e mettere al momento
di sacchi ok sono diamante 2 divisione
iii ok quindi teoricamente dovremmo
contro gli dovremmo avere mediamente 1
diamante di là però se prende il miur
anche avrà run commentato ma non di
avere controllo così semplifichiamo
l'importante è capire che riusciamo a
segnare subito noi e le più alte
l'ex quel fa volgendo ora sta uscendo
una cagata tenevo il parco dire una
letta non avere lato nello turbo
perché no ok ottenuta strada vigilare
non è vero così però importa di chiare
tempo ci sono importa che domani porterà
gas e scapparono roba in volo buono non
ho fatto niente e ho fatto una cacata
male fa in mente ma pericolosi nascosto
quando rimbalza male mi ha fregato
no ci ha fregati tutti e due non ho
fregato 10 milioni gli iscritti e con
battutina questa e ma ce la faremo mai
la bam passo indietro del nostro ok
arrivano orientare aver fiducia infatti
lo stavo per mangiare limpidi di
traverso che culo bravo bravo credo che
gli oil bruttissimo tackle orribile
sono volati tutti e due non hanno
sbloccato questo col saint non si chiama
questo titolo
la fila argentata stranissima aver mai
avuto io vado io so per discutere la
questione saltarmi questo che sei
esperto in dribbling che non ho fatto
ce l'ho fatta perché la quale la fuori
di me che per favore perché ancora più
figo se poi segni lo chiami perche ma
poi la parola
ecco però vite che farà tappa a prato
premio nadal era imprendibile
no mamma mia ke bello denti ma dove
controllo fatto che sarà gigi va e sarà
un controllo al essere un bel controllo
e che non si può dire niente ogni tanto
mi riescono el'abbiamo piega con
l'abbiamo chiusa lì beh 29 secondi io
l'ho perso io a 29 secondi perché
diversa troppo presto per dirlo
l'importante subirla qua ok andati ma
chi è che dal missile
ok si sono cacciati sotto della linea
non lo volevano eccolo una vita antonio
crocetta
ma come un problema tecnico
com'è possibile che un po mi ha fatto
una sega fratricida dispositivo fenomeno
di sky ha vinto quello quello non è
neanche grazie ha vinto un torneo grand
champion
ma di che parliamo problemi al
gravissimo contraire champions i ricci
che ha fatto il passaggio garda del
grand champion pieni da era cosa brutta
ma che ci ha visti che ha detto la crisi
sono scarsi ma in realtà siamo siamo
champion andarti farmelo mettere titolo
treatment che siamo contro un grand
champion e fammelo mettere ma quello
parti sia c'era anche cerchiano grand
champion ma non lo so e me li
distinguono non hanno mai visto noi
l'altra il diamante è anche numerosi
anche vero che ti hanno fatto il
passaggio dall altro
si rimettono provera pacchiotti
bravissimo idolo turbo per fare niente
mi d occhio meno quelle scarsa ok in
proporzione l'altro potrebbe essere
livello silver bene però non ha potuto
fare non lo è però provate ma
l'incredibile però c'è lui che è sicuro
quella nuova
oggi ha fregato una provincia per lo
show dobbiamo vincerla quello dietro si
vede che ne sai quei pochi tutti che fa
li fa per dire addio addio marcava
comprato canna e la profonda arriva
arriva
io non posso credere che lo turco telo
ok ora 616 dei page da oggi non si deve
così se la sono passata in volo ma chi
sono real madrid e ho sbagliato
scusatemi gli spiedi socio dalle mie
giocate è bello porca vacca
ero lì ma era leggermente più alti
maledizione alla vita che fa fregare
bravo va bene ok è che respinta è ma
scusa benissimo forse rimbalza e segnò
una sega proprio va bene però bravo
oddio però è ma c'erano tutti che ci
sono forti york continua per essere così
e mi raccomando
ecco visto però toglilo con calma cosa
che uno saltato forse persona riporta no
perché è rimbalzata male ovvero aspetta
il nostro controllo
ok el'altro mamma mia se mi veniva per
caso per sbaglio era un'ottima cosa
doc a latina lira tega spero nel suo
corso però sul kristic mai la dirà no
non fatto analisi ma no niente magari
perché rimasti stupiti che fa allora
vado subito bravissimo ripartire parti
riporti
no è arrivato in tempo noto provincia
dai passate volta che non solo noi
dai un minuto per vinci un minuto per
vincere poi vai un gravissimo
dobbiamo tenerli qui almeno era per
buongiorno
ciao no non è vero
no la tocco né a controllo noi risultata
come bene far niente lo fa niente lo fa
niente era buonissimo ok niente cacchio
bravo l'ho pregato l'ha avuto in mezzo
se riesco la notte quanto in mezzo a
prendere avrà visto non è salato ma
anche al 30 secondi quanto stiamo
giocando noi solo oddio è bellissimo ma
basta ecco che faccio ha sbagliato io
avere tira tira io non sono affatto
miliardo di tiro entrato nei rispetti ci
avete l'evento era buona
proviamoci all'ultimo tocca e prego è
come fanno riparto per noi ci sono
ancora ci sono ancora gigi dai gts
artista regista vale ragazzi c'era un
gran c'è più di me lo fa niente non fa
niente non so se era che non c'è però
aveva vinto un torneo champion quello
che è quindi vi sia piaciuto iscrivere
anche a cali step è passato questo
episodio di rocket league perché
miglioreremo sempre di più fino ad
arrivare ai campionati mondiali macino
seguito
[Musica]